the chaos in Las Vegas sent thousands
searching for cover from the gunman
senseless violence and his people
scrambled for safety others rushed to
help the wounded Adriana Diaz met some
of those brave men and women who went
against the flow of the crowds and
stepped into what some called a war zone
Adriana good morning good morning we've
seen the footage of the carnage that
took place on the night that started out
as a celebration we've heard the 9-1-1
calls but what gives us the best sense
of humanity are the stories from those
who risked their own lives to help
strangers with concert goers scattering
for cover first responders went to work
many of them into harm's way
you were right in the middle of it yeah
Robert Hayes of the Los Angeles Fire
Department was off duty watching the
show with his wife the shooting started
he realized that now something's gone
wrong then people started screaming as
everyone's running out you're running
toward the same anybody in my profession
would do the same thing I'm just doing
the job I was basically trained to do it
is 29 year career he's responded to
shootings before you see nothing like
this it was a hard sight to see but it
was good to see that everybody came
together I mean they're they're bringing
blankets people are bringing water and
food
what was it in you that made you stay
made you go from person to person to see
how you could help honestly because if
that was someone in my family that's
what I would have wanted somebody to do
for me that's kind of what I'm trained
to do is to just go into action mode and
not worry about myself this man's best
friend was shot three times in the chest
we got him compressed and that's you
know kept compression on his chest he
actually put his finger in the hole and
we keep the compression on I
but there's a lot of heroes out there
yes heroes were everywhere we need your
truck we just need to get people over to
the hospital okay personal vehicles
became ambulances the guy had been shot
in the backside and I thought he was
gonna be okay but he was bleeding and so
he wasn't as serious to shove him into
the ambulance it was right there so I
took him into my car when you see people
coming together and helping people they
kind of let you know that in times of
need that people come together a lot
more despite their efforts many of the
people that Robert Hays and others tried
to save didn't survive Hays told us that
as many as 20 of the people that he
responded to didn't make it Nora oh my
goodness Adriana thank you